the senate hearing for supreme court
nominee katanji brown jackson was held
last week and during that hearing we
watched republicans make some pretty
harsh accusations against her but what
if those accusations say more about the
people making them than they do about
judge jackson i'll explain in a segment
called how did we get here
first let's get one thing straight
katanji brown jackson is qualified to be
on the supreme court she went to harvard
law school she was a public defender and
a supreme court clerk and a district
judge and a court of appeals judge and
she played ronnette in her college
production of the musical little shop of
floors
last i checked that is exactly what the
constitution requires but throughout the
hearings there has been one phrase that
just keeps showing up
what do you say to people say you're
soft on crime the allegation that judge
jackson is soft on crime we see
that she has this tendency to be soft on
crime
is it even possible for a black woman to
be soft on crime the black women i know
give the harshest possible sentences for
crimes like hooton and hollerin or
running in and out that door
let's talk about where the idea of soft
on crime came from and why it matters
when it's used to tear down a black
judge to figure that out let's go back
to the 1960s you know when you could
smoke on airplanes and also in the nicu
the 60s were an interesting time in
southern politics let's see if you
noticed something here's the electoral
map of the deep south in 1956. here it
is again in 1960 and now here's 1964.
now normally when something turns red
that fast it's because it got stung by a
bee so what happened well in 1961
republicans created something called the
southern strategy the southern strategy
sounds like a plan to drive across
mississippi without getting pulled over
if you're black it's not going to work
but
in reality the southern strategy was a
plan crafted by the republican party so
that they could win the south by getting
all the racists to vote for them which
is crazy obviously they can't just put
racists in charge of a party and say we
support jim crow now oh wait my bad
that's exactly what they did in 1964 the
republican party gave their presidential
nomination to barry goldwater a senator
who publicly fought against the civil
rights act outlawing segregation he also
ruined the name barry for the next 50
years and then this guy made it cool
again
republicans also begged strom thurmond
to join their party and bringing in
strong thurman to make your political
party more racist is like bringing in
live grizzly bears to make your dinner
party more exciting
the problem is that it works too well so
here's two facts about strom thurman one
he hated black people so much he once
gave a 24-hour long speech to stop them
from getting civil rights and two he had
a black daughter with his father's 16
year old maid and publicly denied her
existence for over 70 years
honestly i'd rather hang out with the
bears now
why are we rehashing all of this now
well it's because that so-called
southern strategy echoes to this day
during the 1964 campaign goldwater's
vice presidential candidate william e
miller gave a speech warning americans
about ruthless mobs those mobs were
actually black protesters and he used a
new phrase to describe people who
supported them soft on crime even though
the protesters were not criminals this
was the beginning of decades of
republicans using soft on crime as a
euphemism for democrats are going to let
violent negroes come get you you know
like how sorry i missed your text as a
euphemism for i definitely saw your text
but did not feel like answering it
and
since then republicans have used soft on
crime as a euphemism for all kinds of
racist stuff richard nixon talked about
a war on crime while internal memos said
that their campaign plan was to pit the
races against each other ronald reagan
worked so hard to prove he wasn't soft
on crime that by the time he left office
the prison population had doubled and
george h.w bush was so desperate to show
america he hated crime that he did one
of the weirdest things i have ever seen
this
this is crack cocaine
a few days ago by drug enforcement
agents
in a park just across the street from
the white house
it could easily have been heroin or pcp
it's as innocent looking as candy [ __ ]
what candy are you eating
that looks like a bag of mozzarella
cheese
i'm not sure what's worse the fact that
this man brought crack into the white
house or the fact that that's not the
craziest thing i've seen a u.s president
do
that's his hand and that's his daughter
but here's the thing the reason
republicans accuse their opponents of
being soft on crime is because it works
it's a coded way for republicans to tell
voters my opponent will not keep black
people under control in fact the
southern strategy worked so well that it
won republicans the deep south and to
this day democrats have never regained
control so all that brings us back to
judge jackson when jackson is accused of
being soft on crime she gets all the
implications that come with it and to
show just how ridiculous those
accusations can be here's senator come
tom cotton asking the world's dumbest
question do you think we should catch
this is imprisoned more murderers or
fewer murderers
i don't know tom this seems like
something you would figure out without
the help of a future supreme court
justice also why do you look like an
adult version of doug
but
why did he really ask that question it's
because he wants to associate this black
woman with crime he's using her in the
same way his predecessors have for the
past 50 years judge katanji brown has
been endorsed by the international
association of the chiefs of police the
fraternal order of police and 83
democratic and republican former
attorneys general her brother and two of
her uncles served as police officers and
fun fact the supreme court has
absolutely nothing to do with punishing
criminal behavior
sure caller soft on crime but we know
about the southern strategy and we know
what you're really saying it's just like
a text message that says sorry i missed
your text we're not fooled this has been
how did we get here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you